good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you
know how companies sometimes have like
celebrity mailing lists where they send
their new products to a list of
influencers somehow since 2008 I have
been on the celebrity mailing list for
Bananagrams this is actually my 11th
edition of Bananagrams anyway it's
November which means that soon we will
have to buy presents for those we love
and also those we don't love but do feel
obligated to get gifts for and I am your
One-Stop Shopping Guide like if you're
looking for a fun word game I genuinely
recommend Bananagrams you don't need 11
copies of it one will do you got me
Bananagrams you got me to give you free
promo it took 14 years but I did it so
I'm a little biased here but I think the
best gift every year is books especially
my books but also books by other people
like for the lover of non-fiction in
your life I am absolutely Blown Away by
Siddhartha mukherjee's new book the song
of the cell like I didn't think I liked
biology but it turns out I love biology
and also get this I kind of am biology
if you love somebody who loves video
games or just great novels I am so in
love with Gabrielle's Evan's book
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow it's
one of those books where I've given it
to a dozen people and all of them also
fell in love with it if you've got a
friend who might enjoy a super steamy
ex-vangelical romance I really recommend
Corrine by Rebecca Moreau wow and if I
had to pick a favorite young adult novel
I've read this year it would probably be
all my rage by Saba Tahir I've
recommended her books in the past but
this is her first standalone book and
her first contemporary novel and oh my
God it's beautiful also as evidenced by
the fact that I just wrote one I think
essay collections make a great gift like
I love Toni Morrison's the source of
self-regard and Hillary mantel's mantle
pieces the title is by far the worst
thing about the book the book itself is
incredible especially for the person in
your life who loves history or culture
but maybe the vibe this year isn't about
physical Goods at all like maybe give
somebody a one-year patreon membership
to their favorite podcast or YouTube
channel or give them an online course
and something they might be interested
in like Sarah just made this course with
brighttrip about art appreciation and
it's so good I enjoyed it so much that I
went and bought some other bright trips
oh and on that front give the gift of a
walking tour like here in Indianapolis
we have this amazing public historian
named Samson levingston who gives
walking tours of Indianapolis
neighborhoods especially historically
black neighborhoods and I just love
learning from him a lot of towns and
cities have walking tours and I just
think it's a great way to deepen your
understanding of and appreciation for
the place where you live also I always
think it's fun to try to find gifts that
do double good like making the gift
receiver happy but also making the world
better in some way like I'm buying the
kurz Gazette calendars for the Kurtz
Gazette fans in my life because one the
calendars are ridiculously impossibly
beautiful and two they help kurtzkazat
in their mission to reach more people
with great educational video or if you
know causes that your friends and family
are passionate about you can donate
directly to those causes in their their
honor as long as they're not like weird
causes that conflict with your value
system or for the coffee loving person
in your life get them a membership to
the awesome coffee Club so they can have
carefully sourced perfectly roasted
coffee beans and know that 100 of the
profits go to support better maternal
Health in Sierra Leone plus we now have
single bags available if you don't want
a subscription just yet you can find
links to all this stuff in the
doobly-doo but here at the end I'll let
you in on a little secret a lot of times
the best gifts are the ones that aren't
bought at all but are instead made
whether that's making a crossword puzzle
just for someone you care about or
making art for people like Sarah made me
this portrait of myself in the form of a
color palette of my favorite things and
oh God I just love it so much Hank
spoiler alert you're getting a donation
to Partners in Health for Christmas I
will see you on Friday